the recent Manchester derby threw an
ugly spotlight back on racism in the
game fan making monkey gestures towards
United players Fred the team's
midfielder appearing to be hit by a
lighter thrown from the crowd this abuse
is certainly not confined to the UK in
October England faced Nazi salutes and
monkey chants from the Bulgarian crowd
in Sofia and a large group of fans were
ejected from the stadium but enforcement
measures like this aren't stopping the
rise of racism in football it will
continue to occur within stadiums unless
with collective response to salt in the
problem and Wigan Athletic invited Sky
News to see their control room in action
during a match against West Brom the
CCTV covers all areas of the stadium
serious incidents are rare at Wigan the
last was in March but Shaun curry
explains clubs can only do so much in
policing racism it probably goes on in
it probably at most games but it's
probably unidentified because either
people are too frightened to actually
point somebody out and as you can see
now where the stewards are located if
they're at the front of the stand
there's a lot of noise coming at them so
it's difficult to identify one
individual shout or whatever during the
match the control room spots a laser
being shone on the pitch they quickly
identify the perpetrators in the car
park demonstrating how their CCTV has
the ability to see almost everything if
someone in the stands is heard making
racist or homophobic abuse the stewards
would make the control room aware their
cameras are so powerful they can even
make out the seat numbers they've been
monitor the situation and decide whether
an individual is thrown out or arrested
later
as they leave the ground racism remains
the most common form of discrimination
in both professional and grassroots
football making up 65% of all reported
incidents last year racist reports rose
by 43 percent and it isn't limited to
the terraces racism is now the most
common form of football related abuse on
social media making up 62% of incidents
and campaigners expect these figures to
rise even further by the end of this
season I think racism like other forms
of discrimination is becoming more
prevalent in society and so it's
reflected in football as it is in the
rest of society are I can get racially
abused on the tube just as easily as I
can at a football stadium and I think
that's more an indication of broader
things that are going on in society on
the frontline in this fight against
racism a stadium stewards their primary
role is fans safety but David Lyon has
seen crowd behavior deteriorate in his
years doing the job
[Music]
Reyes is young Linda what some are worse
than others but it seems intolerance of
this abuse is on the rise to October's
match between how ingane Yeovil
abandoned after reports of racism and
last month matches at Holland's top two
divisions paused in protest stopping
play perhaps the most effective sanction
of all Sally Lockwood Sky News Wigan